You talk about a strike in 79. I can't taste the factory on the rain the loosens, screws, cold machines, warm ghosts, where humming's your soft, sad, laughing knows you're singing. Hey guys, it's Joel with the Taprate Therapy Collective podcast, and welcome to Part 5 of Psychotherapy on the couch, a psychohistory of American psychology. What psychology can see, what he can't see, and why it has trouble telling the difference. And this will be part five of eight in how long
你谈到了79年的罢工。我无法在松动的螺丝、冰冷的机器、温暖的幽灵以及那哼唱着你那柔和、悲伤、欢笑的歌声中，品尝出工厂在雨中的味道。嘿，大家好，我是Joel，来自Taprate Therapy Collective播客，欢迎收看《沙发上的心理治疗》第五部分，一部美国心理学的心理史。心理学能看到什么，不能看到什么，以及为什么它难以区分两者。这将是八部分中的第五部分，关于它会有多长
it's going to be, because I've finished writing it now. Welcome to part five, the wound that speaks. In a psychiatric hospital in 1910, a woman hears voices, and the voices come from the outside window. They come from trees. They come from the river. They come from the ground beneath the hospital, and they speak in the language of her grandmother. And they tell her the name. of her ancestors. They're not pleasant exactly, but they are familiar, and they belong to the land. In the same hospital in 1935, a man hears voices, and the voices are hungry, they ask him for food, they sound like his children, and they're not threatening, and they are pleading. They want the loaf of bread that is in the kitchen, and the job that is not at the mill,
因为我已经写完了。欢迎来到第五部分，诉说的创伤。1910年，在一家精神病院里，一名女子听到了声音，这些声音来自窗外。它们来自树木，来自河流，来自医院地下的土地，它们用她祖母的语言说话。它们告诉她祖先的名字。它们并不完全令人愉快，但它们很熟悉，而且它们属于这片土地。1935年，在同一家医院，一名男子听到了声音，这些声音很饥饿，它们向他讨要食物，听起来像他的孩子，它们没有威胁性，而是在恳求。它们想要厨房里的那条面包，想要那份不在磨坊里的工作，
and the money that is not in the bank, and the voices are scared because the country is scared. In 1955, a woman hears voices, and the voices are in the radiator, and they are the government agents, and they are conducting surveillance, and the voices have never been in the radiator before, and this is a new decade. But they are there now, and they will remain there until the radiator is replaced by the television, and the television is replaced by the microwave, and the microwave is replaced by the cell phone, and the voices will not leave, they will simply change vehicle. And by 1985, the voices are
以及那笔不在银行里的钱，这些声音感到害怕，因为这个国家感到害怕。1955年，一名女子听到了声音，这些声音在暖气片里，它们是政府特工，正在进行监视，这些声音以前从未在暖气片里出现过，这是一个新的十年。但它们现在就在那里，并且会一直待在那里，直到暖气片被电视取代，电视被微波炉取代，微波炉被手机取代，声音不会离开，它们只会更换载体。到了1985年，这些声音是
implants. By 2005, they are satellites. And by 2020, they come through the algorithm. And they know what she searched. And they tell her what to buy. And they tell her what to trade. And they know what she bought. And they are targeting her with information
植入物。到了2005年，它们是卫星。到了2020年，它们通过算法传来。它们知道她搜索了什么。它们告诉她买什么。它们告诉她交易什么。它们知道她买了什么。它们正用信息锁定她，
meant to destabilize her. And they are sending her advertisements that are messages about herself. And she's not sure whether the paranoia is the delusion or the infrastructure. And all of this is clinical data. If you go to the archives of American psychiatric hospitals and you track the content of psychotic experience across the 20th century, the content changes in lockstep with the cultural environment. Before the Depression, psychotic voices were animistic, tied to nature and geography, ancestry,
意在破坏她的稳定。它们正给她发送关于她自己的广告信息。她不确定这种偏执是妄想还是基础设施。所有这些都是临床数据。如果你去查阅美国精神病院的档案，追踪20世纪精神病体验的内容，你会发现其内容与文化环境同步变化。在大萧条之前，精神病性的声音是万物有灵论的，与自然、地理、祖先有关，
and often benign or encouraging. During the Depression, the voices became fearful, begging for food and services. Compassion and love, and after the war, the voices became antagonistic, persecutory, focused on hierarchical control and surveillance. From the 70s onward, the voices have been technological, electronical, conspiratorial. They speak the language of their time because time is speaking through them. And this is something important. Psychosis is not a content-free malfunction of the brain. It is a malfunction that fills the itself with the fears and the structures of its arrow, because it is the language of the unconscious. The pre-conscious mind is not blank, and then broken, it is full. There's a reservoir, and when the
而且通常是良性的或鼓励性的。大萧条期间，声音变得恐惧，乞求食物和服务。同情与爱，而战后，声音变得具有对抗性、迫害性，专注于等级控制和监视。从70年代开始，声音变得技术化、电子化、阴谋论化。它们说着时代的语言，因为时代正通过它们说话。这是一件重要的事情。精神病并非大脑中无内容的故障。它是一种用其时代的恐惧和结构填充自身的故障，因为它是潜意识的语言。前意识思维并非空白，然后破碎，它是充盈的。有一个蓄水池，当
reservoir cracks, what comes out is whatever was accumulating in it. And the reservoir has a name. Jung called it the collective unconscious, and other traditions have called it other things. But the insight is the same. Below the surface of the individual awareness, there is a deeper layer, where the culture lives in us, and also its shadow lives in our dreams. And it lives in the way that our bodies respond to certain sounds. It lives in the archetypes that keep reappearing across stories that we've never read.
蓄水池破裂时，流出来的是其中积累的一切。这个蓄水池有一个名字。荣格称之为集体潜意识，其他传统也有其他的称呼。但洞见是一样的。在个人意识的表面之下，有一个更深层，文化生活在我们之中，它的阴影也生活在我们的梦中。它生活在我们的身体对某些声音的反应方式中。它生活在我们从未读过的故事中不断重现的原型里。
And it lives most urgently in the places where the culture can't bear to look. And this is where I want you to start the episode, you know, the American unconscious that is absorbing what culture can't process. It absorbs the wounds. And it absorbs the broken promises, the things the eye cannot see. And it absorbs the forced forgettings. And when it has absorbed more than it can hold, it speaks. And it speaks through somatic complaint.
它最迫切地生活在文化不忍直视的地方。这就是我想让你开始这一集的地方，你知道，美国潜意识正在吸收文化无法处理的东西。它吸收了创伤。它吸收了破碎的承诺，那些眼睛看不见的东西。它吸收了被迫的遗忘。当它吸收的超过了它所能承受的，它就会说话。它通过躯体症状说话。
It speaks through dream. It speaks through psychosis. And it speaks through the cults that recruit the exhausted and the conspiracy theories that organize the abandoned. And it speaks through everything except direct acknowledgement, because direct acknowledgement is what the apparatus was built to provide. event. And this is what the paranoid style actually is. It's not a defect of reasoning. It's a language. The wound is using, you know, this language when no other language is available. The language of
它通过梦境说话。它通过精神病说话。它通过招募疲惫者的邪教和组织被遗弃者的阴谋论说话。它通过除直接承认之外的一切方式说话，因为直接承认正是该机制旨在提供的。这就是偏执风格的真正含义。它不是推理的缺陷。它是一种语言。当没有其他语言可用时，创伤正在使用这种语言。这种语言是
metaphor. But it's a metaphor that has forgotten. It is a metaphor that has become uncomfortably and painfully literal. And, you know, once you hear it, you can't unhear it. And I think that's what psychology was supposed to be able to do to hear the metaphor. for what American psychology specifically during this period abandoned and what we are paying for now. So, you know, a brief detour back to the architecture of the thing we are examining. Because I don't want this to sound mystical when I'm describing something that is very neurological. You know, Paul McLean proposed in the 1960s what he called the triune brain. And the model is a simplification. Modern neuroscience has complicated it significantly and said that McLean was reducing
隐喻。但这是一个被遗忘的隐喻。这是一个变得令人不安且痛苦地字面化的隐喻。而且，你知道，一旦你听到了，你就无法再忽略它。我认为这本应是心理学能够做到的——听懂隐喻。为了美国心理学在这一时期具体放弃了什么，以及我们现在正在付出什么代价。所以，你知道，简短地绕道回到我们正在检查的事物的架构上。因为我不想在我描述某种非常神经学的东西时，让它听起来很神秘。你知道，保罗·麦克林在20世纪60年代提出了他所谓的“三位一体大脑”。这个模型是一种简化。现代神经科学已经将其显著复杂化，并指出麦克林是在简化
something so that it could, you know, be understood better and that there was too much, you know, evolution connecting the places that he had separated. But in the core observation, the lens of how the brain evolved is still useful. And the human brain has these evolutionary older layers. There's this reptilian core that handles arousal, threat, survival. And there's this paleomammalian layer, essentially a limbic system that handles emotion in bonding, memory, meaning. And then there's this neo-mammalian layer, the cortex, that handles languages, analysis, and planning. And there's a lot more bridges between them. They're not as separate, as McLean said. But those layers are sort of the core of the architecture in a way that he felt, even if his neuroscience wasn't perfect. I mean,
某些东西以便于更好地理解，而且有太多的进化将他所分离的部分连接在一起。但在核心观察中，大脑进化的视角仍然是有用的。人类大脑有这些进化上较古老的层级。有一个处理唤醒、威胁、生存的爬行动物核心。有一个古哺乳动物层，本质上是处理情感、联结、记忆、意义的边缘系统。然后是这个新哺乳动物层，即大脑皮层，处理语言、分析和规划。它们之间有更多的桥梁。它们并不像麦克林所说的那样分离。但这些层级在某种程度上是架构的核心，即使他的神经科学并不完美。我的意思是，
modern Western culture, you know, privileges the cortex. It treats the cortex as the seat of the self. And it treats the lower layers as equipment. And you have emotions the way you have tonsils. They sit below the real you. You should just manage them. And this is backwards neurologically. And modern neurology, not McLean neurology. You know, those lower layers developed first.
现代西方文化，你知道，赋予大脑皮层特权。它将大脑皮层视为自我的所在地。它将较低的层级视为设备。你拥有情绪就像你拥有扁桃体一样。它们位于真正的你之下。你应该只是管理它们。这在神经学上是倒置的。而现代神经学，不是麦克林的神经学。你知道，那些较低的层级是先发展的。
They run much faster than the cortex. They make most decisions before the cortex is even aware a decision is being made. Or decisions are the wrong word. It's more of a budgeting implicit energy to solve a problem that is anticipating, that will affect. your ability to make a decision. That's what emotion is. To be able to see ahead of time, to get outside of the present and be able to anticipate the future in a way that keeps you alive before you're aware of it. And the philosopher, you know, David Abram, you know, he's in the Jungian tradition. They point at this same thing from different angles. That paleo-mammalian layer,
它们的运行速度比大脑皮层快得多。它们在大脑皮层意识到决策正在做出之前就做出了大部分决策。或者说“决策”这个词用错了。这更像是一种隐含的能量预算，用于解决一个正在预期的、会影响你做出决策能力的问题。这就是情绪。能够提前看到，跳出当下，并能够以一种在你意识到之前就让你保持生存的方式预见未来。而哲学家，你知道，大卫·阿布拉姆，你知道，他属于荣格传统。他们从不同的角度指向同一件事。那个古哺乳动物层，
that limbic emotional layer, is the layer that evolved to experience the world is alive. It experiences meaning before it experiences explanation. It assumes the world is like you. It personifies it, alive like you are. And it experiences threat before it experiences argument. It experiences connection before it experiences category. And this is what animistic cultures were not getting wrong in prehistory. This is what they were attending to.
那个边缘情绪层，是进化出来体验世界是活生生的层级。它在体验解释之前先体验意义。它假设世界和你一样。它将世界人格化，像你一样活着。它在体验论证之前先体验威胁。它在体验分类之前先体验联结。这就是史前万物有灵论文化并没有搞错的地方。这就是他们所关注的。
The experience of the world is an alive thing, as meaningful, as relational. It's not a primitive projection that is laid over a dead material substrate. It is the native mode of the mammalian emotional brain. And the cortex doesn't produce this experience, it just interprets it. And when a culture trains itself to rely on the cortex in the front of the brain, which is really just a filtering mechanism we think now, filtering out this other information, or it's supposed to, we dismiss meaning making of the lower layers of superstition or psychosis. or mental illness. And it doesn't really get rid of that layer when you dismiss them. You can
世界作为一种活生生的事物、作为有意义的、作为关系性的体验。这不是覆盖在死物质基质上的原始投射。它是哺乳动物情绪大脑的本源模式。大脑皮层并不产生这种体验，它只是解释它。当一种文化训练自己依赖大脑皮层（即大脑前部）时，我们现在认为这实际上只是一个过滤机制，过滤掉这些其他信息，或者它本应如此，我们就会将较低层级的意义构建斥为迷信、精神病或精神疾病。当你斥责它们时，并不能真正摆脱那个层级。你可以
stop believing in them, but they still believe in you. It just means that you're no longer aware of how they work. And this is still with us. You know, it's not primitive. It's just the architecture. And the architecture is load-bearing. When the culture won't let the lower layers speak through their proper channels, they speak through improper channels. Peter Levin, who developed somatic experiencing, he points out that Trauma and intuition live in the same neurological neighborhood. They both work through the paleo-mammalian brain, and they both run faster than thought.
停止相信它们，但它们仍然相信你。这只是意味着你不再意识到它们是如何工作的。这仍然伴随着我们。你知道，这不是原始的。这只是架构。而且这个架构是承重的。当文化不允许较低层级通过其适当的渠道说话时，它们就会通过不适当的渠道说话。彼得·莱文，他开发了躯体体验疗法，他指出创伤和直觉生活在同一个神经学邻域。它们都通过古哺乳动物大脑工作，而且它们的运行速度都比思维快。
They both communicate through sensation, image, emotion. You know, rather than the language, they communicate through metaphor. If you shut one down, or you shut down the other, or you take the metaphor literally, it is a sort of high-functioning madness. A culture that numbs itself to its trauma also numbs itself to its intuition, and a person who buries their wound also buries their wisdom. And the American unconscious, I would argue, has been doing this for 130 years, and we have been numbing the
它们都通过感觉、图像、情绪进行交流。你知道，而不是语言，它们通过隐喻进行交流。如果你关闭其中一个，或者你关闭另一个，或者你把隐喻当作字面意思，这是一种高功能的疯狂。一种对自己创伤麻木的文化也会对自己直觉麻木，而一个埋葬自己创伤的人也会埋葬自己的智慧。我认为，美国潜意识已经这样做了130年，我们一直在通过工业纪律、郊区原子化、药物镇静，以及现在的算法捕获来麻木
emotional brain through industrial discipline, suburban atomization, pharmaceutical sedation, and now algorithmic capture. And the trauma has not gone anywhere. It's just lost its proper channel. In the early 20th century, the shadow of the industrial transformation came out in the labor movement. The workers of homestead at Lutow, at Lawrence, were correctly perceiving something that official culture refused to name. The system was rigged, and the promises were faults. And the scientific management being administered to them was not scientific. It was not management.
情绪大脑。而创伤并没有消失。它只是失去了适当的渠道。20世纪初，工业转型的阴影出现在劳工运动中。霍姆斯特德、勒德洛、劳伦斯的工人们正确地感知到了官方文化拒绝命名的事情。系统被操纵了，承诺是虚假的。对他们实施的科学管理并不科学。那不是管理。
It was extraction of wealth and labor. And resources that were on their land. And the Wobblies named it. They didn't have Jung's vocabulary, but they had the perception. They said capitalism is doing this. And they said this is a class that is benefiting and a class that is being crushed. And the crushing is deliberate. And they were in the main, correct.
那是对财富和劳动的榨取。以及他们土地上的资源。而“世界产业工人”组织（Wobblies）命名了它。他们没有荣格的词汇，但他们有感知力。他们说资本主义正在这样做。他们说这是一个正在获利的阶级，而另一个阶级正在被压碎。这种压碎是蓄意的。而且他们大体上是正确的。
Hofstadter would later call this the paranoid style. He would say that movements like the Woblies saw hidden forces, omnipotent conspiracies, demonic enemies. And he wasn't wrong about the rhetoric of the register, but he missed what the register was tracking. The wobblies were paranoid about a real structure. Taylor had literally written that his ideal worker was, and I'm quoting him, more ox than human. And the dehumanization was stated out loud in the founding documents of the behavior's field.
霍夫施塔特后来称之为“偏执风格”。他会说像“世界产业工人”这样的运动看到了隐藏的力量、全能的阴谋、恶魔般的敌人。他对于这种修辞的记录并没有错，但他错过了这种记录正在追踪的东西。工人们对一个真实的结构感到偏执。泰勒曾直言不讳地写道，他理想的工人是——我引用他的话——“更像牛而不是人”。这种非人化在行为主义领域的奠基文件中被大声说出。
The workers weren't imagining it. And what happened to that perception, you know, psychology pathologized it or helped, or it was co-opted, whatever you want. psychology is not just one guy, but behaviorism reframed the workers' resistance as inefficiency. And the rage was engineered away. The accurate perception was medicalized. And the shadow, the unprocessed grief of what was being done to American labor, didn't disappear. It sank. It became somatic. The epidemic of neurasthenia in the early 20th century, the nervous exhaustion, the mysterious fatigues and fainting spells of the office workers and the factory workers and the women trapped in domestic isolation,
工人们并没有想象它。而那种感知发生了什么，你知道，心理学将其病理化了，或者帮助了它，或者它被收编了，随你怎么说。心理学不仅仅是一个人，但行为主义将工人的抵抗重新定义为效率低下。愤怒被工程化地消除了。准确的感知被医疗化了。而阴影，即对美国劳工所作所为的未处理的悲伤，并没有消失。它沉下去了。它变成了躯体化的。20世纪初神经衰弱的流行，那种神经疲惫，办公室职员、工厂工人和陷入家庭孤立的女性的神秘疲劳和昏厥，
was the body reporting what the culture wouldn't let the mouth say. And the rage that couldn't find its target in the factory owner, because the factory owner had made himself invisible by the abstract language of the market, found other targets. It found immigrants. It found Catholics. It found masons.
是身体在报告文化不让嘴巴说出的东西。而那些无法在工厂主身上找到目标的愤怒，因为工厂主通过市场的抽象语言使自己隐形了，找到了其他目标。它找到了移民。它找到了天主教徒。它找到了共济会成员。
It found Jews. It found anarchists. It found, you know, eventually bankers. The first paranoid conspiracy theory of modern America were misfired labor consciousness. They were workers that knew something was being done to them and needed someone to blame. And so they blamed the people that they could see
它找到了犹太人。它找到了无政府主义者。它找到了，你知道，最终是银行家。现代美国第一个偏执的阴谋论是劳工意识的误射。他们是知道有人在对他们做些什么，并且需要找人责怪的工人。所以他们责怪了他们能看到的人，
because they couldn't see the people who were doing the thing. And the shadow of this era, the unprocessed grief of the industrial dispossession, it got passed forward and resolved, and it fed the fascism of the 30s, and it fed the McCarthy paranoia of the 50s, and it fed the militia movements of the 90s,
因为他们看不到那些正在做这件事的人。而这个时代的阴影，工业剥夺带来的未处理的悲伤，被传递下去并演变，它助长了30年代的法西斯主义，助长了50年代的麦卡锡偏执，助长了90年代的民兵运动，
and the rage and the unnamed force that took something from your grandfather's being monetized today by people who have correctly identified that their audience is wounded and have incorrectly identified that the cause of the wound is now a gay person or a trans person or an immigrant or a coastal elite. The wound is real. The map is wrong. And the map will keep being wrong as long as the real wound goes unspoken. By the 1920s and 30s, the shadow had shifted. And you'll remember from episode two, the Norma and Norman statues, the composite figures built from thousands of American measurements, the statistical idea that no one real person
而那种从你祖父身上夺走东西的愤怒和未命名的力量，今天正被那些正确识别出他们的受众是受伤的，但错误地识别出创伤的原因现在是一个同性恋者、跨性别者、移民或沿海精英的人所货币化。创伤是真实的。地图是错的。只要真正的创伤不被说出来，地图就会一直错下去。到了1920年代和30年代，阴影已经转移。你会记得第二集里的诺玛和诺曼雕像，由数千个美国人的测量数据构建的复合人物，一个没有任何真实的人
actually matched, and the Cleveland Plain dealer sponsoring a contest to find the real woman whose body matched enormous proportions. Thousands enter, and no one wins. And this was the birth of a specific American wound, the manufactured inadequacy, the promise of normalcy. That was by design unattainable. And the shadow of this wound was intimate. It was external. It lived in the body. It lived in the mirror, and it lived in the constant low hum of not quite enough that would eventually become the operating system of American consumer life. And psychosis in this period reflected that. The voices became hungry. They begged. They asked for things that the culture could not provide, and they sounded like children who needed to be fed. And the depression had made literal hunger universal.
真正符合的统计学概念，以及《克利夫兰平原商报》赞助的一场寻找身体符合诺玛比例的真实女性的比赛。成千上万的人参加，没有人获胜。这就是一种特定的美国创伤的诞生——制造出来的不足感，对“正常”的承诺。那是设计上无法达到的。而这种创伤的阴影是亲密的。它是外在的。它生活在身体里。它生活在镜子里，它生活在那种“不够好”的持续低鸣中，这种低鸣最终将成为美国消费生活的操作系统。这一时期的精神病反映了这一点。声音变得饥饿。它们乞求。它们索要文化无法提供的东西，它们听起来像需要被喂养的孩子。大萧条使字面上的饥饿变得普遍。
But the psychotic hunger was older and deeper, and it was the hunger of a collective self that had been told it was inadequate and then told the solution was to buy something. Propaganda by Edward Bernays, published in 1928. Chapter 1. Organizing Chaos The conscious and intelligent manipulation of the organized habits and opinions of the masses is an important element in democratic society. Those who manipulate this unseen mechanism of society constitute an invisible government, which is the true ruling power of our country.
但精神病性的饥饿更古老、更深层，这是一个被告知自己不足，然后被告知解决方案是买东西的集体自我的饥饿。《宣传》，爱德华·伯内斯，1928年出版。第一章。组织混乱。对大众有组织的习惯和意见进行有意识和理性的操纵，是民主社会的一个重要因素。那些操纵这种社会看不见机制的人构成了一个隐形政府，这是我们国家真正的统治力量。
We are governed, our minds are molded, our taste formed, our ideas suggested, largely by men we have never heard of. This is a logical result of the way in which our democratic society is organized. Vast numbers of human beings must cooperate in this manner if they are to live together as a smoothly functioning society. Our invisible governors are, in many cases, unaware of the identity of their fellow members in the inner cabinet. They govern us by their qualities of natural leadership, their ability to supply needed ideas, and by their key position in the social structure. Whatever attitude one chooses
我们受到统治，我们的思想被塑造，我们的品味被形成，我们的想法被暗示，很大程度上是由我们从未听说过的人所为。这是我们民主社会组织方式的逻辑结果。如果人类要作为一个平稳运行的社会生活在一起，就必须以这种方式进行合作。我们的隐形统治者在许多情况下，并不知道内阁中其他成员的身份。他们通过天生的领导才能、提供所需想法的能力以及在社会结构中的关键位置来统治我们。无论一个人选择
to take towards this condition, it remains a fact that in almost every act of our daily lives, whether in the sphere of politics or business, in our social conduct or our ethical thinking, we are dominated by the relatively small numbers of persons, a trifling faction of our 120 million, who understand the mental processes and social patterns of the masses. Edward Bernays, who we mentioned before, who was Freud's nephew, understood this perfectly. Bernays had read his uncle, and he knew about repression,
采取什么态度对待这种情况，事实仍然是，在我们日常生活的几乎每一个行为中，无论是在政治还是商业领域，在我们的社会行为或道德思考中，我们都受到相对少数人的支配，这是我们1.2亿人中微不足道的一小部分，他们了解大众的心理过程和社会模式。爱德华·伯内斯，我们之前提到过，他是弗洛伊德的侄子，完全理解这一点。伯内斯读过他叔叔的书，他知道压抑，
he knew about the unconscious, and he knew that if you could name what people were repressing and then sell them a product that pretended to address it, then they would buy it forever. American psychology watched, as we talked about earlier, and would Bernays invent the cigarette as a sign of women's liberation? And it led him. Even the Depression didn't interrupt advertising.
他知道潜意识，他知道如果你能命名人们正在压抑的东西，然后卖给他们一个假装能解决它的产品，那么他们就会永远购买它。美国心理学在观察，正如我们之前谈到的，伯内斯发明了香烟作为女性解放的标志？这引导了他。即使是大萧条也没有中断广告。
It just professionalized it. And the technique of unconscious manipulation that Freud's nephew had developed in the 20s, got refined in the 30s, as the only way to move the product in a broken economy. You don't sell the thing. You sell the relief from the culture that has made you feel about yourself, for not having the thing. And that grammar, once it took hold, became the operating language of American consumer life. We still speak it, but it has to change every era so that we don't
它只是使其专业化了。弗洛伊德的侄子在20年代开发的潜意识操纵技术，在30年代得到了完善，作为在破碎经济中推动产品的唯一方式。你不卖那个东西。你卖的是从那种让你因为没有那个东西而对自己感觉糟糕的文化中解脱出来的感觉。而那种语法，一旦扎根，就成为了美国消费生活的操作语言。我们仍然在说它，但它必须在每个时代改变，这样我们才不会
recognize it. Advertising from the 50s looks silly, and we're used to advertising of our time. And the conspiracy theories of this era had a specific shape. They were populist. They were anti-elite. They were anti-Semitic. Father Kaufflin on the radio in the 1930s, railing against the Jewish bakers. Huey Long, you know, saying that share our wealth. The American first movement, these were again correctly tracking something. The wealth concentration of the Gilded Age had created a genuine oligarchy, and the Depression was genuinely engineered in part by financial speculation. And the ordinary American, who felt like an invisible force,
认出它。50年代的广告看起来很傻，而我们习惯了我们时代的广告。这个时代的阴谋论有一种特定的形状。它们是民粹主义的。它们是反精英的。它们是反犹太的。卡夫林神父在1930年代的广播中，抨击犹太银行家。休伊·朗，你知道，说“分享我们的财富”。“美国优先”运动，这些再次正确地追踪了一些东西。镀金时代的财富集中创造了一个真正的寡头政治，而大萧条在某种程度上确实是由金融投机策划的。而普通的美国人，感觉自己像一股隐形的力量，
even though his labor was moving the country, had been collapsed by these forces. And that metaphorical map was not wrong, but the forces were not a Jewish cabal. They were diffused through an economic system that nobody controlled and everyone served. And because the map was wrong, the rage went to the wrong target. It went to Jews. It went to immigrants. It prepared the ground for the fascism that would almost capture America in the later 30s. And the shadow of this era, the inadequacy, the manufactured wanting did not resolve. It just got passed forward and it became.
尽管他的劳动在推动这个国家，却被这些力量压垮了。那个隐喻性的地图并没有错，但这些力量不是一个犹太阴谋集团。它们通过一个没有人控制、每个人都服务的经济系统扩散开来。因为地图错了，愤怒发泄到了错误的目标上。它发泄到了犹太人身上。它发泄到了移民身上。它为30年代后期几乎要占领美国的法西斯主义铺平了道路。而这个时代的阴影，那种不足感，那种被制造出来的匮乏，并没有解决。它只是被传递下去，并成为了
the operating logic of post-war advertising. It became the grammar of suburban consumption. It became eventually the infinite scroll. And the curated Instagram grid is the direct descendant of the Norma statue, the same wound, but in higher resolution. And American psychology still will sometimes post about these things, trying to use the same language of the thing it's attacking. But it doesn't really psychoanalyze them.
战后广告的操作逻辑。它成为了郊区消费的语法。它最终成为了无限滚动。而精心策划的Instagram网格是诺玛雕像的直接后裔，同样的创伤，但分辨率更高。而美国心理学有时仍然会发布关于这些事情的内容，试图使用它正在攻击的事物的相同语言。但它并没有真正对它们进行心理分析。
And it doesn't bring them into, therapy or start to diagnose the effect that they have because they're too normal. And it always has to look at the abnormal, a pathologizing, you know, a pathologizing psychology, never looks at a culture that is pathological. It doesn't feel like it can. And so after this came the bomb. The shadow of the Cold War is different and kind from what became before it. You know, previous wounds were social and economic, and the atomic wound was existential. For the first time in the history of the species, humans possess the capacity to instantly delete themselves. There were children doing duck and cover drills. Like we talked
它并没有把它们带入治疗，或者开始诊断它们所产生的影响，因为它们太“正常”了。它总是必须审视异常，一种病理化的心理学，从不审视一个病态的文化。它觉得它不能。所以在这之后是炸弹。冷战的阴影在性质上与之前的东西不同。你知道，以前的创伤是社会和经济的，而原子创伤是存在主义的。在物种历史上，人类第一次拥有了瞬间抹除自己的能力。有孩子在做“蹲下并掩护”演习。就像我们之前谈到的，
about before, they knew that the desk wouldn't really save them. And the adults knew too. And the adults knew the children knew. And the drill continued anyway. And this specific injury of the post-war era, it is the injury of performed, reassured. in the face of known catastrophe, sleepwalking into the apocalypse, pretending that you have control over something that you don't, and refusing to acknowledge the self-evident. You know, it's the injury of being told by the institutions responsible for your safety that a wooden desk will save you from a thermonuclear fire
他们知道课桌并不能真正救他们。大人们也知道。大人们知道孩子们知道。但演习还是继续了。这种战后时代的特定伤害，是面对已知灾难时表现出的、被安抚的伤害，梦游般地走向末日，假装你对某些你无法控制的事情拥有控制权，并拒绝承认显而易见的事实。你知道，这是被负责你安全的机构告知一张木桌能把你从热核火球中救出来，
and being required to pretend that you believe it. And the injury is not the bomb. The injury is the lie about the bomb. And the lie told children something that they would carry into a, adulthood. The authorities lie. They lie about the most important things, and they lie with the full weight of their institutional credibility, and that lying is required. But more than that, if you're not lying to yourself, you're crazy. The cultural artifact the best captures this is tension, like we talked about before. In the 60s, in the early 70s, especially in the crying of
并被要求假装你相信它的伤害。伤害不是炸弹。伤害是关于炸弹的谎言。而这个谎言告诉了孩子们一些他们会带入成年期的事情。权威在撒谎。他们在最重要的事情上撒谎，而且他们以其机构信誉的全部重量撒谎，而这种撒谎是必须的。但更重要的是，如果你不对自己撒谎，你就是疯了。最能捕捉到这一点的文化产物是品钦，就像我们之前谈到的。在60年代，在70年代早期，特别是在《拍卖第四十九批》和《万有引力之虹》中，它们不是偏执的小说。它们是关于偏执的小说，
lot 49 and gravity's rainbow, they're not paranoid novels. They're novels about paranoia, And specifically, they're novels about what happens when you live in a culture where the official stories are all lying. And the only way to keep your sanity is to assume that there is a truer story underneath. And you have to find the truer story, even if it kills you. Pension would write in Gravity's Rainbow that right now a million bureaucrats are diligently plotting death. And some of them even know it. And the paranoia kept being validated. M.K. Ultra turned out to be real.
具体来说，它们是关于当你生活在一个官方故事都在撒谎的文化中时会发生什么的小说。保持理智的唯一方法是假设下面有一个更真实的故事。你必须找到那个更真实的故事，即使它会杀了你。品钦在《万有引力之虹》中写道，此刻有一百万官僚正在勤奋地策划死亡。甚至有些人知道这一点。而偏执不断得到验证。MK Ultra被证明是真的。
The CIA had been dosing American citizens with LSD in safe houses in New York and San Francisco, conducting mind control experiments on unwitting subjects. Cointel Pro turned out to be real. The FBI had been infiltrating domestic civil rights organizations and assassinating leaders. The Pentagon Papers turned out to be real. The government had been lying about Vietnam for decades. The church committee revelations were real. The conspiracy theorists of the 60s were not paranoid.
中央情报局一直在纽约和旧金山的秘密据点用LSD给美国公民下药，对不知情的受试者进行精神控制实验。Cointel Pro被证明是真的。联邦调查局一直在渗透国内民权组织并暗杀领导人。五角大楼文件被证明是真的。政府几十年来一直在关于越南的问题上撒谎。丘奇委员会的揭露是真的。60年代的阴谋论者并不偏执。
They were perceptive. and the conspiracy was in the ceiling. Even though many of the conspiracy theorists weren't right, big enough conspiracy theories got validated that everybody felt right. And now for the next 30 minutes, as the world turns. And I gave it a great deal of thought, Grandpa. Here is a bulletin from CBS News. In Dallas, Texas, three shots were fired at President Kennedy's motorcade in downtown Dallas.
他们是有洞察力的。而阴谋就在天花板里。尽管许多阴谋论者并不正确，但足够大的阴谋论得到了验证，以至于每个人都觉得正确。现在，接下来的30分钟，随着世界的转动。我对此进行了深入思考，爷爷。这是来自哥伦比亚广播公司新闻的一则快讯。在德克萨斯州达拉斯，三声枪响射向了肯尼迪总统在达拉斯市中心的摩托车队。
The first reports say that President Kennedy has been seriously wounded by this shooting. This picture has just been transmitted by wire. It is a picture taken just a moment or two before the incident. If you can zoom in with that camera, we can get a closer look at this picture. From Dallas, Texas, the flash apparently official President Kennedy died at 1 p.m. Central Standard Time. 2 o'clock Eastern Standard Time, some 38 minutes ago. Vice President Lyndon Johnson has left the hospital in Dallas, but we do not know to where he has proceeded.
第一份报告称，肯尼迪总统在这次枪击事件中受了重伤。这张照片刚刚通过电报传送。这是在事件发生前片刻拍摄的照片。如果你能用那台摄像机放大，我们可以更仔细地看看这张照片。来自德克萨斯州达拉斯，快讯，显然是官方消息，肯尼迪总统于中部标准时间下午1点去世。东部标准时间2点，大约38分钟前。副总统林登·约翰逊已经离开了达拉斯的医院，但我们不知道他去了哪里。
Presumably he will be taking the oath of office shortly and become the 36th president of the United States. And then underneath all of it, JFK and the assassination was the specific moment. the timelines split in American public consciousness. You watched the president die on television, and you watched his assassin die on television two days later, and the official explanation insulted anybody with a pulse.
据推测，他很快就会宣誓就职，成为美国第36任总统。而在这一切之下，肯尼迪和暗杀事件是特定的时刻。时间线在美国公众意识中分裂了。你在电视上看着总统死去，两天后你在电视上看着他的刺客死去，而官方解释侮辱了任何有脉搏的人。
Whatever actually happened in Dallas, the culture's failure to process what had happened, created a wound that generations would inherit. The Warren Commission papered over something, and the papering was itself, the injury, and everyone knew something was being hidden, and nobody could say, what and the knowledge that could not be spoken became the permanent operating condition of the
无论达拉斯到底发生了什么，文化未能处理所发生的事情，创造了一个几代人都会继承的创伤。沃伦委员会掩盖了一些事情，而这种掩盖本身就是伤害，每个人都知道有什么东西被隐藏了，没有人能说出是什么，而这种无法说出的知识成为了美国潜意识的永久操作条件。
American unconscious. No matter what happened to Dallas and no matter why, the timeline changed. Psychosis in this period changed accordingly. The voices became surveillance. The voices became persecution. Cabals. And the voices spoke the language of the real covert operations. The real government was running. And when a patient in 1968 says the CIA is watching her, she's both delusional and on the evidence, underestimating what the CIA is actually doing. Because the CIA was watching people. It was watching a lot of people.
无论达拉斯发生了什么，无论原因是什么，时间线改变了。这一时期的精神病也相应改变。声音变成了监视。声音变成了迫害。阴谋集团。而声音说着真正的秘密行动的语言。真正的政府正在运行。当1968年的一名病人说中央情报局在监视她时，她既是妄想的，又根据证据，低估了中央情报局实际在做的事情。因为中央情报局确实在监视人。它在监视很多人。
And it had a program for it, and her delusion was tracking a real structure. She had just inserted herself into it in a way that wasn't accurate. And the conspiracy theories of the 60s, 70s, and 80s got some of the biggest ones right. The tobacco companies were lying. The asbestos companies were lying. The sugar industry was paying scientists to blame fat. The pharmaceutical companies were hiding the harms of their own product. Each of these was called a conspiracy theory until it wasn't.
而且它有一个计划，她的妄想正在追踪一个真实的结构。她只是以一种不准确的方式将自己插入其中。而60年代、70年代和80年代的阴谋论确实弄对了一些最大的阴谋。烟草公司在撒谎。石棉公司在撒谎。糖业公司在付钱给科学家去责怪脂肪。制药公司在隐藏自己产品的危害。每一个都被称为阴谋论，直到它不再是。
And the paranoid style kept being vindicated, and the mainstream kept being embarrassed. And the credibility of the official institutions kept eroding, and nobody in the institutions seemed to notice that this was happening because of them. And everybody knows. And everybody knows. that the plague is coming. Everybody knows that it's moving fast. Everybody knows that the naked man and woman
而偏执风格不断得到平反，主流不断感到尴尬。官方机构的信誉不断受到侵蚀，而机构中似乎没有人注意到这是因为他们自己。每个人都知道。每个人都知道。瘟疫即将来临。每个人都知道它移动得很快。每个人都知道那个赤裸的男人和女人
but just a shining artifact of the past. However, the wound was not distributed evenly, and black Americans inherited a different order of a share of it. I want to promote Jonathan Metzell's book, The Protest Psychosis Here. But when black Americans, Black Americans began organizing during this time. They began marching and they began demanding rights.
只是过去的一个闪亮的人造物。然而，创伤并没有均匀分布，美国黑人继承了不同秩序的份额。我想在这里推荐乔纳森·梅策尔的书《抗议精神病》。但是当美国黑人，美国黑人在这一时期开始组织起来。他们开始游行，他们开始要求权利。
And they expressed rage that had been accumulating for generations. And before the civil rights movement, schizophrenia and American medical literature was described as a disorder of middle-class white women. It was depicted as a docile confusion, a withdrawal, or, you know, a sort of jumping at shadows. It was tragic, but it wasn't threatening. It was a heightened feminine condition, as how most psychologists thought of it. And then schizophrenia was rewritten. The archival record documents that transformation pretty well. In the late 50s and through the 60s, the diagnostic criteria for schizophrenia in American
他们表达了积累了几代人的愤怒。在民权运动之前，美国医学文献中的精神分裂症被描述为中产阶级白人女性的疾病。它被描绘成一种温顺的困惑、退缩，或者，你知道，一种对阴影的惊跳。它是悲剧性的，但没有威胁性。这是一种高度女性化的状况，大多数心理学家是这样认为的。然后精神分裂症被重写了。档案记录很好地记录了那种转变。在50年代末和60年代，美国精神病学文献中精神分裂症的诊断标准发生了转变。敌意、攻击性、偏执，针对白人权威。
psychiatric literature shifted. Hostility, aggression, paranoia, directed at white authority. And these became the new emblems of the disease. And the diagnosis started getting applied to black men at rates that had no medical justification at all, men who were political active. were committed to state hospitals, and their political rhetoric was entered into the charts as symptoms, and their anger at a racist society was classified as a pathology. Psychology had begun to be the enforcer of the normal on a mass scale, and a normal that
这些成为了这种疾病的新标志。这种诊断开始以完全没有医学依据的比率应用于黑人男性，那些政治活跃的男性被送进州立医院，他们的政治修辞被作为症状记录在病历中，他们对种族主义社会的愤怒被归类为病理。心理学已经开始成为大规模强制“正常”的执行者，而这种“正常”现在，不是诺玛或诺曼，而是一个庞大的官僚系统。这就是那个机构的阴影。美国精神病学机构在面对黑人政治意识时，没有把黑人当作病人来对待，而是无法承认美国黑人实际上在说什么。所以它把这种说法转化为了症状。它把对系统性种族主义的准确感知转化为了精神疾病。它用抗精神病药物和机构化、电休克疗法来治疗这种疾病。而弗朗茨·法农早就预见到了这一点。
was now, not a norma or a Norman, but a massive bureaucratic system. And this was the shadow of that institution. The American psychiatric establishment when it was confronted with black political consciousness, instead of treating black people as a patient, could not acknowledge what black Americans were actually saying. So it transformed the saying into a symptom. And it transformed the accurate perception of systemic racism into a mental illness. And it treated the illness with antipsychotics and institutionalization with electroshock therapy. And France Fanon had been seeing this coming for a while.
他认为殖民医学在被殖民者身上所谓的“疯狂”，通常是对殖民状况的理性反应。精神病患者对迫害并没有妄想。迫害是真实的。病理在系统中，而不是在病人身上。而美国精神病学，想象自己是这种中立的科学观察者，实际上是正在被抗议的同一个系统的分支。所以这种创伤持续存在。黑人社区对心理健康机构的不信任并非不理性。精神分裂症是一种真实的疾病。这是一种真实的疾病，除了抗精神病药物外，它不会随着治疗而消失。而且，种族主义也是真实的。然而，对于治疗一种确实影响某些人以及非洲裔美国人比例更高的真实疾病存在不信任，原因仍在争论中。这里的水很浑。而且这种不信任被添加到了美国心理学本应治疗的整个人群中，因为它不会倾听他们。它不会倾听或准确地看到和听到他们。
argued that what colonial medicine called insanity in colonized people was usually a rational response to the colonial condition. The psychotic was not delusional about persecution. The persecution was real. The pathology was in the system, not in the patient. And the American psychiatry, which imagined itself as this neutral scientific observer, was in fact an arm of the same system being protested. And so this wound persists. The distrust of men's mental health institutions in black communities is not irrational. Schizophrenia is a real disease. It's a real disease that does not go away with therapy,
它从未完全正视这一事实。它的诊断类别在多个点上成为了武器。该领域想要谈论文化能力和隐性偏见，但它至今不想谈论这个档案。革命不会被电视转播。革命不会由施乐公司分四部分提供给你，且没有商业插播。革命不会向你展示尼克松吹号角，由约翰·米切尔、艾布拉姆斯将军和斯皮罗·阿格纽领导冲锋的画面。去吃从哈莱姆避难所没收来的猪蛾，革命不会被电视转播。
does not go away with many forms of treatment other than antipsychotics. And also, racism is real. However, there was a mistrust of treating a very real illness that does affect some people and Africans, Americans at a higher percentage for reasons that are still debated. The water was moneyed here. And there was a distrust that was added to an entire population of people that American psychology was supposed to treat because it would not listen to them. And it would not listen or see them and hear them accurately.
然后是里根，阴影再次改变。如果冷战的阴影是国外的外部敌人，炸弹、阴谋集团和兰利，效率福音的阴影，现在是内在的。它是责任本身的阴影。在系统性地阻止你掌控自己生活的条件下，被告知你要对自己生活负责的阴影，以及这让你陷入的双重束缚，因为你没有选择且无法改变的结果而受到指责的阴影。
And it never fully reckoned with that fact. Its diagnostic categories have been at multiple points weapons. And the field wants to talk about cultural competency and implicit bias, but it does not want to talk about this archive to this day. The revolution will not be televised. The revolution will not be brought to you by Xerox in four parts without commercial interruptions. The revolution will not show you pictures of Nixon blowing a bugle and leading a charge by John Mitchell, General Abrams and Spiro Agnew. To eat hog moths confiscated from a Harlem sanctuary, the revolution will not be televised.
它从未完全正视这一事实。它的诊断类别在多个节点上成为了武器。该领域至今仍想谈论文化胜任力和内隐偏见，却不愿谈论这一档案。革命不会被电视转播。革命不会由施乐公司分四部分呈现给你，且没有商业广告插播。革命不会向你展示尼克松吹响号角，带领约翰·米切尔、艾布拉姆斯将军和斯皮罗·阿格纽冲锋的画面。革命不会去吃从哈莱姆避难所没收来的猪蛾，革命不会被电视转播。
And then came Reagan, and the shadow changed again. If the Cold War, Shadow was an external enemy abroad, the bomb, the Kabbal and Langley, the efficiency gospel shadow, was now internal. It was the shadow of responsibility itself. The shadow of having been told that you were in charge of your own life in conditions that systematically prevented you from ever being in charge of your own life and the double bind that that put you in, the shadow of being blamed for outcomes that you did not choose and could not change.
随后里根上台，阴影再次改变。如果说冷战时期的阴影是国外的外部敌人、炸弹、阴谋集团和兰利，那么效率福音的阴影现在变成了内部的。那是责任本身的阴影。那是被告知在系统性地阻止你掌控自己生活的条件下，你却要对自己的生活负责的阴影，以及由此让你陷入的两难境地；那是因你未曾选择且无法改变的结果而受到指责的阴影。
I traced in episode four how Reagan sold Americans on a story where the government was the enemy in the market was the solution. And where the social safety net was oppression and dismantling it was freedom. But what I didn't fully name there was that the psychological cost of that, was that when the culture tells you that every outcome in your life is the product of your own choices, and then it engineers conditions where the outcomes are catastrophic, it has set you up for a particular kind of collapse. Because if the outcome is bad and the outcome is your fault, then you are bad.
我在第四集中追溯了里根是如何向美国人兜售这样一种叙事的：政府是敌人，市场是解决方案；社会安全网是压迫，而拆除它就是自由。但我当时没有完全点出的是，这种叙事带来的心理代价是：当文化告诉你，你生活中的每一个结果都是你自己选择的产物，然后又设计出一种必然导致灾难性结果的环境时，你就被推向了一种特定的崩溃。因为如果结果很糟糕，而这结果又是你自己的错，那么你就是一个糟糕的人。
and the ideology of the individual responsibility in the absence of collective protection becomes a machine for manufacturing shame. But an enemy for that shame had to be found. And the satanic panic as a cultural event ran roughly from 1980 to the early 1990s and over 12,000 claims of organized satanic ritual abuse. Almost none were ever substantiated. Daycare workers jailed on the testimony of children coached by a therapist, using discredited, recovered memory techniques.
在缺乏集体保护的情况下，个人责任的意识形态就成了一台制造羞耻感的机器。但必须为这种羞耻感找到一个敌人。撒旦崇拜恐慌作为一种文化事件，大致从1980年持续到1990年代初，期间出现了超过12,000起关于有组织撒旦仪式虐待的指控。几乎没有一起得到证实。日托中心的工作人员仅仅因为被治疗师诱导的孩子们的证词而入狱，而这些治疗师使用的是早已被否定的“恢复记忆”技术。
Books like Michelle remembers taken seriously by law enforcement. And for some reason, the author of them was able to keep his license, even though the subject of the book was a patient who he was having sex with while he wrote the book and later left his wife for. I don't know why Canada did that. But, you know, Geraldo Riviera, the Ingram case in Washington, where a police officer, under sustained interrogation
像《米歇尔记得》（Michelle Remembers）这样的书被执法部门认真对待。出于某种原因，该书作者即使在书的主题——也就是他正在与之发生性关系的一位病人——被曝光后，依然保住了执照，后来他还为了她抛弃了妻子。我不知道加拿大为什么要那样做。但是，你知道，杰拉尔多·里维拉（Geraldo Rivera），华盛顿的英格拉姆案（Ingram case），一名警察在持续审讯下，
came to believe that he had ritually abused his own children in ceremonies that he could not actually remember in which forensic evidence eventually concluded had never happened. There were hundreds of lives destroyed and the apparatus of moral panic
开始相信自己在一些仪式中虐待了自己的孩子，而这些仪式他根本记不起来，法医证据最终也断定这些仪式从未发生过。有数百人的生活被毁了，而道德恐慌的机器
operating at full capacity wearing the borrowed authority of clinical psychology. And here's the point. The satanic panic was not random. It was not a freak eruption of superstructure. of superstition in a modern country. It was the exact psychological problem
以满负荷状态运转，借用了临床心理学的权威。重点在于：撒旦崇拜恐慌并非偶然。它不是现代国家中迷信思想的突发性爆发。它正是这一集一直在探讨的心理问题，
that this episode has been circling, manifesting at the cultural level, at the precise moment when the official psychological apparatus had lost the capacity, handle symbolism, to handle metaphor. Geraldo Riviera would say in clips that are not available online,
在文化层面上的显现，恰好发生在该官方心理学机构已经丧失了处理象征意义和隐喻能力的时候。杰拉尔多·里维拉在网上找不到的片段中曾说，
in 1995, I am convinced that I was terribly wrong, and that many innocent people have been devastated by this. I want to apologize to this. people and to my viewers for my role in this. I've been a firm believer in this movement, and I've come to realize I and others that we were all terribly wrong. I am so sorry. I have to admit that I was one of the many who fell for it. It was a kind of mass hysteria that I helped fuel. Heraldo had mistaken, as the or a shaman, the emotional forces that he was speaking to and unleashing as truth. And the people who were participating in the mass hysteria mistook the pain
在1995年，我确信我大错特错了，许多无辜的人因此受到了毁灭性的打击。我想向这些人以及我的观众为我的所作所为道歉。我曾是这场运动的坚定信徒，但我意识到，我和其他人一样，我们都错得离谱。我非常抱歉。我必须承认，我是众多上当受骗者中的一员。这是一种我推波助澜的群体性癔症。里维拉误将他所谈论和释放的情绪力量当作了真理，就像萨满一样。而那些参与群体性癔症的人，误将他们感受到的痛苦
that they were feeling for a literalized symbol, one whose claims were so insane that no serious adult could take it seriously. However, millions and millions had. And like everything else, the seeds of this had been laid much earlier. Second way feminism had by the mid-70s produced this enormous accumulation of accurate testimony about sexual exploitation of women and children. Andrew Dworkin was writing and Catherine McKinnon was writing and Kate Millett had published sexual politics in 1970 and Susan Brownmillers against our will came out in 1975. And for the first time in American history, the actual scale of domestic violence, of incest and the pornographic objectification of women was no longer being sedated by the sedative
当作了一种字面化的象征，其主张荒谬到没有任何严肃的成年人会当真。然而，数以百万计的人却当真了。像其他所有事情一样，这一切的种子早在很久以前就种下了。到70年代中期，第二波女性主义已经积累了大量关于女性和儿童遭受性剥削的准确证词。安德里亚·德沃金（Andrea Dworkin）在写作，凯瑟琳·麦金农（Catharine MacKinnon）在写作，凯特·米利特（Kate Millett）于1970年出版了《性政治》，苏珊·布朗米勒（Susan Brownmiller）的《违背我们的意愿》于1975年出版。美国历史上第一次，家庭暴力、乱伦和色情化女性的实际规模，不再被郊区的镇静剂所掩盖。
of the suburbs. The pain of the suburbs was being brought to light, the unpleasant underbelly under the green grass and the white picket fences and the grills with the hot dogs. It was being named aloud in mainstream discourse, and testimony was overwhelming, was undeniable, and it described a pattern of systemic abuse that the culture had no symbolic language to process anymore. And at the same time, they were Catholics and they were evangelicals who were registering something real. They were registering that the sexual revolution had not liberated everyone, that the pornography industry had exploded in the 70s into this $8 billion enterprise, that something had been lost when the symbolic container that used to surround
郊区的痛苦被公之于众，绿草地、白色栅栏和烤热狗的烤架下那令人不快的阴暗面被揭露出来。它在主流话语中被大声说出，证词是压倒性的、不可否认的，它描述了一种文化已经无法再用象征性语言来处理的系统性虐待模式。与此同时，天主教徒和福音派教徒也察觉到了一些真实的东西。他们察觉到性革命并没有解放所有人，色情产业在70年代爆炸式增长为80亿美元的企业，当曾经围绕着性、尽管并不完美的象征性容器被溶解时，有些东西已经丢失了。
sexuality, however imperfect, was dissolved. And they weren't wrong about that. They had their own distortions and their own agenda, but they were not hallucinating the content of what they were naming. The culture was getting worse in ways that they were diagnosing accurately. And children were being sexualized in advertising, something that they had never seen in the 50s or even the 60s. And teenagers were being pulled into pornography. And the broader culture, the atmosphere had changed in ways that the parents of young children found terrifying, and that terror was not paranoid invention. So you had two groups, feminists on one side and religious conservatives on the other, who had under normal circumstances almost nothing in common, especially politically,
他们在这点上并没有错。他们有自己的扭曲和议程，但他们并没有幻觉化他们所指出的内容。文化正在以他们准确诊断出的方式恶化。儿童在广告中被性化，这是他们在50年代甚至60年代从未见过的。青少年被卷入色情制品中。更广泛的文化氛围发生了变化，这让幼儿父母感到恐惧，而这种恐惧并非偏执的臆想。所以你有两群人，一边是女性主义者，另一边是宗教保守派，在正常情况下，他们几乎没有任何共同点，尤其是在政治上，
but they were registering the same thing. And that sexualization and exploitation and exploitation of women and children had reached a level that the culture was not processing. And so both groups needed language for what they were seeing. Neither group had it. They found a common cause in the satanic pan. And this is where the apparatus fails of American Psyche, because the traditional language for this kind of perception was symbolic. It was religious.
但他们察觉到了同样的事情。那种对女性和儿童的性化与剥削已经达到了文化无法处理的程度。因此，两组人都需要一种语言来描述他们所看到的东西。两组人都没有。他们在撒旦崇拜恐慌中找到了共同点。这就是美国心理学机构失败的地方，因为对于这种感知的传统语言是象征性的。它是宗教性的。
It was mythological. You could talk about the loss of the sacred. You could talk about the violation of the temple of the body. You could talk about evil in the sense that the older traditions meant evil as a structural feature of reality. that the individual ego could be captured by. And the symbolic container held the accurate perception at the right level of the abstraction. It did not require you to believe in a literal conspiracy
它是神话性的。你可以谈论神圣的丧失。你可以谈论身体神殿的亵渎。你可以谈论邪恶，即老一辈传统所理解的作为现实结构特征的邪恶，个人自我可能会被其俘获。象征性的容器在正确的抽象层面上保持了准确的感知。它不需要你相信一个字面上的阴谋
or a literal devil. And it required you to understand that something real was happening at the level of the cultural soul. But the symbolic container had been dissolving for 60 years. And the apparatus should have helped people, the American psychology apparatus, should have helped people navigate
或一个字面上的魔鬼。它要求你理解在文化灵魂层面正在发生真实的事情。但象征性的容器已经溶解了60年。而该机构本应帮助人们，美国心理学机构本应帮助人们驾驭
what the container could no longer longer hold and what had been actively repressing with symbolic literacy. But American psychology was losing any kind of symbolic or metaphorical literacy. It was taking these things literally and losing a relationship to an unconscious mind. It was transitioning during reganomics to, or the precursors to reganomics, CBT, cognitive and behavioral therapy, therapy where the therapist was a technician, where everything was psychoed education, everything was instruction. And so at this exact moment, when the nuance was stripped out of therapy, and clinicians were being taught to literalize, you know, distorted cognitions, you know, it treating metaphor as an error to be corrected rather than a communication to be received just became normal. And just as the culture needed symbolic language to hold what it was seeing, the official psychology was unlearning symbolic language as fast as it could and throwing the depth and the unconscious traditions out of psych. And so, the perception, which was real, was forced into a literal form. The feelings about sexual exploitation
容器无法再容纳的东西，以及它一直以来用象征性素养积极压制的东西。但美国心理学正在失去任何象征性或隐喻性的素养。它将这些事物字面化，并失去了与潜意识的关系。在里根经济学期间，或者说里根经济学的前身时期，它正在向CBT（认知行为疗法）过渡，这是一种治疗师作为技术员的疗法，一切都是心理教育，一切都是指令。因此，就在这个时刻，当治疗中的细微差别被剥离，临床医生被教导要字面化那些“扭曲的认知”，将隐喻视为需要纠正的错误而不是需要接收的交流时，这变得正常了。正如文化需要象征性语言来容纳它所看到的东西一样，官方心理学却在尽可能快地遗忘象征性语言，并将深度和潜意识传统从心理学中剔除。因此，这种真实的感知被迫进入了一种字面化的形式。关于性剥削的感受
were accurate, but they got attached to a literal conspiracy theory of millions of Satanists, building tunnels under every single street in America, and broadcasting their intentions through magical spells, put into pop music, it could only be revealed when they were played backwards and scrutinized. This isn't news. This isn't literal reality. This is metaphor. But the culture had lost the ability to understand it, so it took these religious impulses as literal truth. Andrea Dworkin and Jerry Falwell ended up on the same side of the anti-pornography fight in the early 80s, because the symbolic register had collapsed and they were both reaching for whatever remained. When this is the psychological tragedy of the satanic panic, it was a correct perception wearing a false costume.
是准确的，但它们被附着在一个字面化的阴谋论上：数百万撒旦崇拜者在美国每一条街道下挖掘隧道，并通过放入流行音乐中的魔法咒语广播他们的意图，只有在倒放和仔细审查时才能揭示。这不是新闻。这不是字面现实。这是隐喻。但文化已经失去了理解它的能力，所以它将这些宗教冲动视为字面真理。安德里亚·德沃金和杰瑞·法威尔（Jerry Falwell）在80年代初的反色情斗争中站在了同一边，因为象征性语境已经崩溃，他们都在伸手抓取任何剩下的东西。这就是撒旦崇拜恐慌的心理悲剧，它是一个穿着虚假外衣的正确感知。
Something was being done and still is to women and children that the culture was and is not processing. The satanic conspiracy theory was not real, and the underlying wound was. But because the symbolic apparatus failed, the only way the wound could surface was a mass hallucination of literal devil-worshippers, when the metaphor no longer available as a metaphor became a delusion, just as it had in every other phase of American history. The wound speaks. And here is the part that unites all of these threads. I think the late 70s was, in a very real sense, where we were doing some of the best psychotherapy and psychology that America had ever done. You know, before we threw it out, and the satanic panic was the coffin nail.
有些事情正在——并且仍然在——对女性和儿童做着，而文化过去和现在都无法处理。撒旦阴谋论不是真的，但潜在的创伤是真实的。但由于象征性机构的失败，创伤浮出水面的唯一方式就是一场关于字面魔鬼崇拜者的集体幻觉，当隐喻不再作为隐喻存在时，它就变成了妄想，就像美国历史上的每一个阶段一样。创伤在说话。这就是将所有这些线索联系在一起的部分。我认为70年代末在某种非常真实的意义上，是我们进行过的一些最好的心理治疗和心理学研究的时期。你知道，在我们抛弃它之前，而撒旦崇拜恐慌是棺材上的最后一颗钉子。
The feminist testimony was psychology. And the revived interest in Jung through people like James Helmand. And Joseph Campbell was psychology. The early somatics of, you know, bioenergetics and the descendants of Wilhelm Reich. And a lot of them were abusive. A lot of them were bad. I'm saying it was also a very messy and bad period. But there was a lot of good in it.
女性主义的证词是心理学。通过詹姆斯·希尔曼（James Hillman）和约瑟夫·坎贝尔（Joseph Campbell）等人对荣格的重新关注是心理学。早期的躯体疗法，比如生物能量学和威廉·赖希（Wilhelm Reich）的后继者们，也是心理学。其中很多是虐待性的。很多是糟糕的。我说这是一个非常混乱和糟糕的时期。但其中也有很多好的东西。
And that early body-based work that would later become somatic experiencing was psychology. The Eastland synthesis, at its best, was psychology. Gregory Bateson was still writing. R.D. Lang was still practicing. The transpersonal movement was seriously wrestling with what consciousness was
那些后来演变成躯体体验疗法的早期身体工作是心理学。伊萨兰（Esalen）的综合疗法在最好的时候是心理学。格雷戈里·贝特森（Gregory Bateson）还在写作。R.D.莱恩（R.D. Laing）还在执业。超个人心理学运动正在认真地与意识是什么进行搏斗，
and where we come from as existing creatures. What it meant to be alive. Existentialism, spirituality, hadn't been separated and pruned away from the profession. And there was a genuine flowering of integrative, symbolically literate, body-aware, psychology happening in those years. And it was mixed absolutely with an enormous amount of self-indulgent nonsense, cults, abuse,
以及作为存在的生物我们从哪里来。活着意味着什么。存在主义、灵性，还没有从这个职业中被分离和修剪掉。在那些年里，确实出现了一种整合的、具有象征素养的、身体意识强的心理学繁荣。它绝对混合了大量的自我放纵的胡言乱语、邪教、虐待、
conspiracy theories, people who were new-age grifters. And some people who were genuinely mentally ill that were practicing, you know, in claiming to treat mental illness. But the signal and the noise were tangled together in a way that made them nearly impossible to separate from a distance. And the culture confronted with the tangle of those things, eventually just gave up on separating them. And it threw the baby out with the bathwater. It decided that the whole category, symbolic psychology, body-based psychology, depth psychology, any psychology that could hold metaphor was contaminated by the excesses of the era, that it was their fault.
阴谋论，一些是新时代的骗子。还有一些真正患有精神疾病的人在执业，声称治疗精神疾病。但信号和噪音以一种从远处看几乎无法区分的方式纠缠在一起。文化在面对这些事物的纠缠时，最终放弃了区分它们。它把孩子和洗澡水一起倒掉了。它认定整个类别——象征性心理学、身体心理学、深度心理学，任何能够容纳隐喻的心理学——都被那个时代的过度行为污染了，这是它们的错。
the metaphor speakers that we had had a satanic panic at all. And Reagan and Thatcher arrived with this disinfectant. The efficiency machine was sold as a return to sobriety after decades of excess, rationalism, and this promise of a cure. And it was more sober, it was also flatter, and it was structurally incapable of doing the work that had been abandoned. And the cognitive behavioral turn, the DSM3 checklist, the 15-minute med check, all of it that we'll talk about later
那些隐喻的讲述者们，我们竟然发生了撒旦崇拜恐慌。里根和撒切尔带着这种消毒剂来了。效率机器被作为一种在几十年的过度、理性主义之后的清醒回归，以及一种治愈的承诺来兜售。它确实更清醒，但也更平庸，并且在结构上无法完成那些被放弃的工作。认知行为转向、DSM-3清单、15分钟的药物检查，所有我们稍后会谈到的东西，
that was offered to the culture had been so burned the culture was hurting so much that by those symbolic excesses of the 70s, they welcomed this reduction, this flattening and this simplification of self. And we would no
提供给文化的东西，文化已经被70年代那些象征性的过度行为烧伤了，伤得太深了，以至于他们欢迎这种缩减、这种扁平化和这种自我的简化。我们将不再
longer be doing that weird stuff. We would be doing science. And the price of the promised rigor was that we lost for a generation, the tools to hold the kind of perception that the feminists and the Catholics had both been trying to name and we gave up on trying to treat the wound at all or even in trying to find it and the satanic panic was the last grasp
做那些奇怪的事情。我们将做科学。而这种承诺的严谨性所付出的代价是，我们整整一代人失去了工具来保持女性主义者和天主教徒都试图命名的那种感知，我们放弃了尝试治疗创伤，甚至放弃了尝试寻找它。撒旦崇拜恐慌是最后一个
of a culture that was still trying to speak symbolically about something that it could feel but it couldn't articulate when the panic collapsed around 1992 or 1993 and the false convictions started getting overturned and the recovered memory therapy was exposed as just suggestion and confirmation bias. The conclusion that the culture drew was not that we needed better symbolic tools. The conclusion was that symbolic thinking itself was dangerous. And from now on, we would stick to what could be measured. And psychology went along with this conclusion because psychology was already by that point committed to exactly that program. And we got lost in the moment when the baby went out with the bathwater.
试图以象征方式谈论某种它能感觉到却无法表达的事物的文化的最后挣扎。当恐慌在1992年或1993年左右崩溃，虚假定罪开始被推翻，恢复记忆疗法被揭露仅仅是暗示和确认偏误时，文化得出的结论并不是我们需要更好的象征工具。结论是象征性思维本身是危险的。从现在开始，我们将坚持那些可以被测量的事物。心理学顺应了这个结论，因为心理学在那时已经致力于那个程序。我们在孩子和洗澡水一起倒掉的那一刻迷失了。
I said that three times, sorry. And we lost the generation of clinicians who would have been able to integrate the body work with the depth work, with the cultural critique. And we lost the institutional spaces where somebody like Jung could have worked in the open. And we lost the willingness to take religious experience seriously as clinical data or transpersonal experience.
我说了三次，抱歉。我们失去了一代能够将身体工作与深度工作、文化批判相结合的临床医生。我们失去了荣格这样的人可以在公开场合工作的制度空间。我们失去了将宗教体验或超个人体验作为临床数据认真对待的意愿。
Any kind of experience that wasn't quote unquote normal, which I'm sorry is a part of this thing. You know, everything is. that is normal is not psychology, where it's not, psychology doesn't have a target that it's shooting for as much as we tried to make after that point. There isn't a bull's eye of normal. And we lost the interdisciplinary conversation that had been producing real insights at Eastland at the Macy conferences. We lost specifically the capacity to hold the feminist testimony in its full weight, because that testimony required symbolic register to metabolize. And we just declared that the symbolic register
任何不属于所谓的“正常”的体验，抱歉，这也是这件事的一部分。你知道，一切都是。正常的不是心理学，或者说，心理学并没有一个它正在瞄准的目标，尽管我们在那之后试图这样做。没有一个“正常”的靶心。我们失去了在伊萨兰、梅西会议上产生真正见解的跨学科对话。我们特别失去了容纳女性主义证词全部重量的能力，因为这些证词需要象征性语境来代谢。而我们只是宣布象征性语境
was off limits forever. And the abuse survivors who were accurately reporting what had happened to them got categorized as borderline personality disorder. The ritual abuse hysteria became the pretext for dismissing all recovered memory, including considerable portion of what was describing some actual events. And the clinical apparatus, having panicked about the panic, retreated into pure symptom management and it stayed there. And so when I'm telling you that the wound speaks,
永远禁止进入。那些准确报告所发生之事的虐待幸存者被归类为边缘性人格障碍。仪式虐待癔症成为了驳回所有恢复记忆的借口，包括其中相当大一部分描述了一些真实事件的内容。临床机构在对恐慌感到恐慌后，退缩到了纯粹的症状管理，并一直停留在那里。所以当我告诉你创伤在说话时，
I'm telling you that this is what speaking looks like when the official channels have been closed. The satanic panic was the wound speaking, the only language that remained available to it, which was literalized metaphor, conspiracyism, and the degraded form of mythological thinking. The mass hallucination is the collective unconscious
我是在告诉你，当官方渠道被关闭时，说话看起来就是这个样子。撒旦崇拜恐慌是创伤在说话，它唯一剩下的语言，即字面化的隐喻、阴谋论和神话思维的退化形式。集体幻觉是集体潜意识
his last attempt to communicate before the cognitive behavioral ice age set in. And then the self-help industry rose up to monetize what the apparatus would no longer address. You want to make it. difference in life, you want to stop just being concerned with what's important, like what people think of you and what your position is and how much money you got and your posture in the community and what you believe in and all that other stuff that ultimately doesn't make a difference?
在认知行为冰河时代到来之前的最后一次沟通尝试。然后自助产业兴起，将机构不再解决的问题货币化。你想在生活中有所作为，你想停止只关心那些重要的事情，比如别人怎么看你、你的地位、你有多少钱、你在社区里的姿态、你的信仰以及所有那些最终无关紧要的事情吗？
You want to play in the realm of difference making, then you need to be willing to take a stand. That was Warner Earhart of E.S.T. Irvin Yalom in his book, Existential Psychology, makes fun of Erhard. And he talks about how a lot of the self-help movement was trying to offer this alternative to the culture that was really just a repackaging of the same thing, that, you know, Erhard and others, you know,
你想在有所作为的领域里玩，那么你需要愿意采取立场。那是EST（Erhard Seminars Training）的沃纳·埃哈德（Warner Erhard）。欧文·亚隆（Irvin Yalom）在他的书《存在心理学》中嘲笑了埃哈德。他谈到自助运动是如何试图提供这种对文化的替代方案，而这实际上只是对同样事物的重新包装，你知道，埃哈德和其他人，你知道，
EST and different things, you know, ultimately something like Nexium, would just rearrange the tags on what was rebellion and what was allowed and make you feel like you were doing something that was rebellious by really making you, you know, with, you know, taking a lot of your money, this sort of coercive persuasion to just do the thing that you were doing anyway.
EST和其他不同的东西，你知道，最终像Nexium这样的东西，只是重新排列了什么是反叛、什么是允许的标签，让你觉得你在做一些反叛的事情，而实际上只是让你，你知道，拿走你很多钱，这种强制性的说服让你去做你本来就在做的事情。
You know, Yoham talks about the hypocrisy of preaching individual growth while demanding obedience to get the individual growth. You're never pointed inward by these guys. You're empowered through them, not through yourself. as American psychology could have stepped up, you know, again, to do. And, you know, Werner-E-Hard's, you know, EST trainings, they started in 71. He was one of the bigger guys.
你知道，亚隆谈到了宣扬个人成长却要求服从以获得个人成长的虚伪。这些人从来不会指引你向内看。你是通过他们被赋能，而不是通过你自己。正如美国心理学本可以站出来，你知道，再次去做的那样。而且，你知道，沃纳·埃哈德的EST培训，它们始于71年。他是大人物之一。
I don't mean to pick on him. I don't think he's terrible or the worst. I don't even know that he's guilty of the things he got canceled for later. But, you know, he would say, you know, if your life is bad, you chose it. If you want a better life, take responsibility, which in practice meant paying Werner-Hard for a weekend of being screamed at in a hotel ballroom with no bathroom breaks. And EST evolved into Landmark eventually, which is still running.
我不是要针对他。我不认为他很糟糕或最坏。我甚至不知道他是否对他后来被取消资格的事情负有责任。但是，你知道，他会说，你知道，如果你的生活很糟糕，那是你选择的。如果你想要更好的生活，承担责任，这在实践中意味着付钱给沃纳·埃哈德，在一个没有厕所休息的酒店宴会厅里被大吼大叫一个周末。EST最终演变成了Landmark，至今仍在运行。
Same pitch, smoother package. But what's the difference in that in the 80s culture that's telling you that anyway? The reason why it feels liberating is because it's packaged like it's rebellion and this authentic connection, but it's the same thing that the culture was already doing, which is why it's familiar and why it's not threatening to you, why you're willing to pay $15,000 to hear it. And, you know, the darkest version of that logic would become something like Nexium, which is the cult, you know, if people have watched the vow in any of these documentaries,
同样的推销，更平滑的包装。但这与80年代告诉你同样事情的文化有什么区别？它之所以让人感觉解放，是因为它被包装成反叛和真实的连接，但它与文化已经在做的事情是一样的，这就是为什么它很熟悉，为什么它对你没有威胁，为什么你愿意花15,000美元去听它。而且，你知道，那种逻辑最黑暗的版本会变成像Nexium这样的东西，也就是邪教，你知道，如果人们看过《誓言》（The Vow）或任何这些纪录片，
the true crime people. You know, it, it, NXium is this, you know, heightened, modernized evolution of taking that same vocabulary of self-help and then using it to run what, you know, turns out to be a sex trafficking operation. You know, Keith Reneer, the founder of Nexium or the guy who benefited from it, other people kind of did the work, you know, told his followers that they were in, charge of their reality and that their suffering was a choice and that obedience to him was actually enlightenment and the structure was identical to EST. Nexium was not a deviation from this self-help
那些真实犯罪的人。你知道，Nexium是这种，你知道，将同样的自助词汇高度现代化演变，然后利用它来经营最终被证明是性贩运的操作。你知道，Nexium的创始人基思·拉尼尔（Keith Raniere），或者从中受益的人，其他人做了工作，你知道，告诉他的追随者他们掌控着自己的现实，他们的痛苦是一种选择，对他服从实际上就是启蒙，结构与EST完全相同。Nexium并不是对这种自助模式的偏离，
model of the way that you have real freedom is that you become a slave and the way that you have real authenticity is that you do what I tell you to. It was this model followed to its logical conclusion. And here's what the important self-help cult does. It takes the woman. It takes the wound of the efficiency gospel, and the shame of being told that you are responsible for outcomes you cannot control, and then it reframes the shame as opportunity. If you're responsible for everything, then you are powerful, and the only thing standing between you and the life that you want is your own inadequacy. And then there is a technique that can fix that inadequacy, and someone's selling it. But ultimately, it's pointing you further and further to be by yourself, to be alone.
即你获得真正自由的方式是你成为奴隶，你获得真正真实性的方式是你做我告诉你的事。这是这种模式遵循其逻辑结论的结果。这就是重要的自助邪教所做的。它利用了女性。它利用了效率福音的创伤，以及被告知你对无法控制的结果负责的羞耻感，然后将羞耻感重新定义为机会。如果你对一切负责，那么你就是强大的，唯一阻碍你和你想要的生活之间的东西就是你自己的不足。然后有一种技术可以修复这种不足，而有人在卖它。但最终，它是在引导你越来越远离你自己，让你孤独。
and while you're part of a group. And so the cult is the efficiency gospel wearing a therapist coat. And psychology was largely absent, you know, from this niche, which is why that self-help movement in the 80s and the 90s exploded. And the niche that psychotherapy is absent from now is probably kind of the blogger, holistic health manosphere area. But 80s and 90s, this is what it was. And American psychology let the self-help industry take over the territory that it had abandoned.
而你同时又是群体的一部分。所以邪教是穿着治疗师外衣的效率福音。而心理学在很大程度上缺席了，你知道，在这个利基市场，这就是为什么80年代和90年代的自助运动爆炸式增长。而心理治疗现在缺席的利基市场可能是博客、整体健康、男性社群领域。但在80年代和90年代，这就是它的样子。美国心理学让自助产业接管了它所放弃的领地。
Again, it ceded more territory. And because the Efficiency Gospel had remade clinical therapy into a six-session symptom reduction protocol, ideally, it never really worked. People came from more than six sessions. There was no space in the clinical hour for this question of meaning, of purpose, of why. And so people went to EST, and they went to Landmark, and people went to Tony Robbins, and people went to eventually people like Jordan Peterson. And the shadow of that era was this shame. It was this exhausted gaslit self-blame of a generation that had been told that the world was fair and that it could feel that it wasn't, though. And it couldn't say why. And so somebody telling you, you're in this
它再次割让了更多领地。而且因为效率福音已经将临床治疗改造成了一个六次疗程的症状减轻方案，理想情况下，它从来没有真正起作用。人们来的次数超过六次。临床时间里没有空间来讨论意义、目的、为什么的问题。所以人们去了EST，去了Landmark，人们去了托尼·罗宾斯（Tony Robbins），人们最终去了像乔丹·彼得森（Jordan Peterson）这样的人那里。那个时代的阴影就是这种羞耻感。这是一代人精疲力竭、被煤气灯效应折磨的自我指责，他们被告知世界是公平的，但他们能感觉到它并不公平。而且他们说不出原因。所以有人告诉你，你在这个
huge group of people, but making you more alone is kind of an addictive thing. And somebody telling you, you're going to have ultimate power, but only through giving your money, and your time and your mind to me felt like an empowering authentic experience. And so the semantic exhaustion of the white-collar worker whose job description kept expanding while their salary stayed flat, who was interchangeable now in this system where they couldn't really have an individual brand. This was incredibly appealing, where the culture would only hire normal. All of the identity stuff went here. And so the suburban opioid, crisis that would explode in the 2000s, killing people who'd followed every rule and
庞大的群体中，但让你更加孤独，这是一种令人上瘾的事情。有人告诉你，你将拥有终极权力，但只能通过把你的钱、你的时间和你的思想交给我，这感觉像是一种赋能的真实体验。所以白领工人的语义枯竭，他们的工作描述不断扩大，而薪水却保持不变，在这个系统中他们现在是可互换的，他们无法真正拥有个人品牌。这非常有吸引力，文化只会雇佣“正常人”。所有的身份认同的东西都去了这里。所以郊区的阿片类药物危机在2000年代爆发，杀死了那些遵循每一条规则却
discovered that the rule still didn't work, just became the same thing as Valium. It became the same sedation, and people acted like it was the fault of drug pushers, or it was the fault of, and the psychopharmacological industry does bear a lot of blame for that one. But, you know, the drug was needed because of why. The capacity for the psychopharmological company to make billions and billions of dollars. in that niche was there because what? Why buy the drug?
发现规则仍然不起作用的人，就变成了和安定（Valium）一样的东西。它变成了同样的镇静剂，人们表现得好像这是毒贩的错，或者这是……的错，而精神药理学产业确实对此负有很大责任。但是，你知道，药物之所以被需要是因为原因。精神药理学公司在那个利基市场赚取数十亿数十亿美元的能力之所以存在是因为什么？为什么要买药？
Why don't we have these epidemics in other countries? And the current era's shadow, I think, what is genuinely new, is not in content, but in architecture of the same stuff. Every prior era's shadow was distorted across a population. People could find each other. The factory worker could meet in a union hall. The suburban housewife could eventually read the feminine mystique. There was a sort of antidote.
为什么我们在其他国家没有这些流行病？我认为当前时代的阴影，真正新的东西，不在于内容，而在于同样事物的架构。每一个前时代的阴影都在人口中扭曲。人们可以找到彼此。工厂工人可以在工会大厅见面。郊区家庭主妇最终可以读到《女性的奥秘》（The Feminine Mystique）。有一种解毒剂，
that led to the next phase, the next iteration of advertising. And the anti-war protesters could at least march. The collective shadow could find collective expression, even if it was distorted, collective expression. And the algorithm doesn't let you do that. It individuates, and it delivers a personalized shadow to every phone. Your feed is not my feed. The outrage being fed to you is calibrated to your specific vulnerabilities,
导致了下一个阶段，广告的下一次迭代。反战抗议者至少可以游行。集体阴影可以找到集体表达，即使它是扭曲的集体表达。而算法不允许你这样做。它使个体化，并向每部手机传递个性化的阴影。你的信息流不是我的信息流。喂给你的愤怒是根据你的具体弱点校准的，
and it is different from the outrage being fed to me. And the nature of these phones means that that outrage is not a seminar that you go to when somebody tells you to and ha ha, he-he, this is kind of a cult. I'm just going to go to one meeting. Oops. It felt really good because I watched all of these people in an EST seminar, you know, go through the same thing where they kept saying it's not my fault, it's not my fault, and then, oh, it is my fault. And then I realized that, oh, all these people did that and they kind of overcame this thing and then we felt better. And now I'm really into it. Now that isn't a seminar that.
它与喂给我的愤怒不同。这些手机的本质意味着那种愤怒不是你去参加的研讨会，有人告诉你，哈哈，嘿嘿，这有点像邪教。我只是去参加一次会议。哎呀。它感觉真的很好，因为我在EST研讨会上看到所有这些人，你知道，经历了同样的事情，他们一直说这不是我的错，这不是我的错，然后，哦，这是我的错。然后我意识到，哦，所有这些人都做了那个，他们克服了这个东西，然后我们感觉好多了。现在我真的很投入。现在那不是一个研讨会，
somebody from your work goes to and that happens. It's a phone that is grafted to your nervous system. It is something that has becoming functionally not separate from your brainstem. And this is why the contemporary conspiracy theories like QAnon and the Manosphere and pastel conspiratuality and the old algorithmic left-wing doom loops, they've left this specific texture that is new. And they're not mass movements in the old sense. their individual
你工作中的某个人去参加，然后发生了那种事。它是一部嫁接到你神经系统上的手机。它正在变得在功能上与你的脑干没有区别。这就是为什么当代阴谋论，如QAnon、男性社群、柔和的阴谋灵性（conspiratuality）和旧的算法左翼厄运循环，它们留下了这种新的特定质感。它们不是旧意义上的群众运动。它们是个体
calibrated wounds that speak two hashtags where no one actually ever will understand you. You are more alone and in a room with more people than could ever fit into the analog
校准的创伤，对着标签说话，没有人真正会理解你。你比在任何模拟房间里能容纳的人数更多的情况下，更加孤独，并且身处一个房间里。
rooms. And so two people who believe in QAnon may believe in completely different QAnon's. One of those QAnons may be halfway right or mostly right. The movement isn't a body of belief. It's the shape of a wound filled in by whatever content the algorithm happens to deliver. And the feeling that these people have, that something's being done to them, that their nervous
所以两个相信QAnon的人可能相信完全不同的QAnon。其中一个QAnon可能是对的一半或大部分是对的。运动不是一个信仰体系。它是被算法碰巧传递的任何内容所填充的创伤的形状。这些人的感觉，即有什么事情正在对他们做，他们的神经
systems are being manipulated, that the news is lying, that they are being steered towards emotional states that they did not choose. That feeling is accurate. And something is being done to them. The platforms optimized for engagement, which is to say for the neurological responses that keep people scrolling, outrage and fear and comparison and status threat. You know, just the need to be an individual that is expressing something new and finding something in an aesthetic that is individually liberating and empowering. And the tech industry has a quarter century of A-B testing research here on how to capture your attention. And it's invested that research in products designed to do exactly that.
系统正在被操纵，新闻在撒谎，他们正在被引导向他们没有选择的情绪状态。那种感觉是准确的。确实有什么事情正在对他们做。平台针对参与度进行了优化，也就是说，针对让人们不断滚动、愤怒、恐惧、比较和地位威胁的神经反应。你知道，只是作为一个个体表达新事物、在美学中找到某种个体解放和赋能的东西的需求。科技产业在这里有四分之一个世纪的A-B测试研究，关于如何捕捉你的注意力。它将这项研究投入到旨在做到这一点的产品中。
So when a Q&N believer says that they can feel that they're being manipulated, they are right. they are being manipulated. And when they reach for the cabal of democratic pedophiles as the mechanism, they're wrong. And that one of these parties is good and the other's bad or, you know, whatever. I'm not, this isn't a political podcast. All I'm saying is that the answer is not as simple as those movements will diagnose you to believe. And the complexity of the system is not as simple as any of them will tell you. The underlying perception is correct.
所以当一个QAnon信徒说他们能感觉到他们正在被操纵时，他们是对的。他们确实正在被操纵。当他们伸手去抓民主党恋童癖阴谋集团作为机制时，他们错了。而且这些政党中有一个是好的，另一个是坏的，或者，你知道，无论什么。我不是，这不是一个政治播客。我只是说，答案并不像那些运动诊断你相信的那样简单。系统的复杂性并不像他们中任何一个会告诉你的那样简单。潜在的感知是正确的。
they're not paranoid about nothing. They're paranoid about something, and the thing that they are paranoid about is the thing that is actually paranoid making, which is the platform delivering the paranoia. The medium is the disease. And this is the consistent pattern across every era that we've gone through.
他们不是对虚无感到偏执。他们是对某事感到偏执，而他们感到偏执的事情正是实际上制造偏执的事情，即传递偏执的平台。媒介就是疾病。这是我们经历过的每个时代的一致模式。
People feel that rewiring. The feeling is accurate, and technology is a part of it, but technology is not even really the problem. The attribution is wrong. Labor-era-era workers felt that the industrial, dis-possession, and they attribute it to masons and Catholics. And Depression-era workers felt the economic capture, and they attributed to Jewish bankers,
人们感觉到那种重连。这种感觉是准确的，技术是其中的一部分，但技术甚至不是真正的问题。归因是错误的。劳工时代的工人感受到了工业剥夺，他们将其归因于共济会和天主教徒。大萧条时代的工人感受到了经济掠夺，他们将其归因于犹太银行家，
and Cold War citizens felt the covert state, or they blamed something that somebody was doing in Russia. And they attributed often correctly to the CIA or the FBI, though they sometimes expanded that attribution into territory that the evidence didn't really support. And efficiency-era workers felt the gaslighting of personal responsibility. They attributed it to their own inadequacy. The algorithmic era user, you know, feels the platform capture and they attribute it to
冷战时期的公民感受到了秘密国家，或者他们责怪俄罗斯有人在做某事。他们通常正确地将其归因于中央情报局或联邦调查局，尽管他们有时将这种归因扩展到证据并不真正支持的领域。效率时代的工人感受到了个人责任的煤气灯效应。他们将其归因于自己的不足。算法时代的用户，你知道，感受到了平台捕获，他们将其归因于
the deep state or, you know, to people who are either so ill-defined that it isn't even a thing or who are so specific that there's no way that those people have the power to do the thing they're being accused of. And the attribution is always culturally available. The feeling is always neurologically accurate. and the apparatus that was supposed to help people distinguish between the accurate feeling and the wrong attribution, that apparatus psychology spent the 20th century making itself unable to do any of that work, to help with any of those problems, or even to see them.
深层政府，或者，你知道，归因于那些要么定义不清以至于根本不存在，要么非常具体以至于那些人根本没有权力做他们被指控的事情的人。归因总是文化上可用的。感觉在神经学上总是准确的。而本应帮助人们区分准确感觉和错误归因的机构——心理学——在20世纪花费了大量时间使自己无法做任何那种工作，无法帮助解决任何那些问题，甚至无法看到它们。
And I want to step back and say, you know, what I think is actually happening is, you know, that we just keep walking through this era. We keep walking through these eras. And I think that the American unconscious has been carrying for over a century, quantity of unprocessed material that exceeds the capacity of the official channels to process. And every era has added to the reservoir and the industrial dispossession, the manufactured inadequacy, the atomic terror, the covert state, the efficiency gaslighting, the algorithmic capture. None of these wounds was ever fully acknowledged. None was ever collectively grieved. And none was ever
我想退后一步说，你知道，我认为实际上正在发生的是，你知道，我们只是不断地走过这个时代。我们不断地走过这些时代。我认为美国潜意识已经承载了一个多世纪，数量超过了官方渠道处理能力的未处理材料。每个时代都增加了水库，工业剥夺、制造的不足、原子恐怖、秘密国家、效率煤气灯效应、算法捕获。这些创伤中没有一个被完全承认。没有一个被集体哀悼。也没有一个被
integrated, you know, in the Jungian sense of making the unconscious content conscious and letting the conscious self adjust to include it, even if it's bad, this being able to see it as part of the cure. And instead, each wound was medicalized. It was turned into individual symptoms. It was treated with individual interventions. So if you want to take a theory like Carl Jung and turn it into neurology, his phenomenology into neurology, it's just intergenerational trauma plus culture. It's this wound that couldn't be metabolized in one generation getting metabolized badly by the next. And it's what psychology had the tools to address and refuse to use any of those tools for. And the conspiracy theories, the cults, the self-help industries, the mass psychotic content,
整合，你知道，在荣格意义上，即让潜意识内容意识化，并让意识自我调整以包含它，即使它是坏的，这种能够将其视为治愈的一部分。相反，每个创伤都被医疗化了。它被变成了个体症状。它被个体干预所治疗。所以如果你想把像卡尔·荣格这样的理论变成神经学，他的现象学变成神经学，它只是代际创伤加上文化。这是在一个世代中无法代谢的创伤，被下一代糟糕地代谢了。这就是心理学有工具去解决，却拒绝使用任何这些工具去解决的问题。阴谋论、邪教、自助产业、大规模精神病内容，
all of it is this reservoir overflowing and is the wound speaking because the mouth has been sewn shut. And it is speaking through the body. It's speaking through the dream. It's speaking through the delusion. It's speaking through the retweet. It's speaking through the algorithm now. It's speaking through everything except the one channel that was built to research. receive it, which was psychology, the industry that's supposed to be dealing with.
所有这些都是这个水库溢出，是创伤在说话，因为嘴巴已经被缝上了。它正在通过身体说话。它正在通过梦说话。它正在通过妄想说话。它正在通过转发说话。它现在正在通过算法说话。它正在通过除了本应被建立来接收它的那个渠道之外的一切说话，那个渠道就是心理学，那个本应处理这些问题的行业。
Because therapy has been captured and optimized and made into this 15-minute med check, or the incentive structure, at least, is pushing it that direction. I don't think it's entirely gone. I know a lot of great therapists. You know, the incentive structure is against them. You know, then there are very few places where we are able to see ourselves in a mirror that could reflect something like this at us anymore. And there were moments where it could have gone differently.
因为治疗已经被捕获、优化，并变成了这种15分钟的药物检查，或者至少激励结构正在向那个方向推动。我不认为它完全消失了。我认识很多伟大的治疗师。你知道，激励结构对他们不利。你知道，那么我们能够再次在镜子中看到自己的地方很少了，那面镜子可以向我们反射出这样的东西。曾经有时刻，事情可能会有不同的发展。
Because I think the conspiracy theories instincts, again, are always correct, or not always, but people are telling you that they're hurt, believe them. Maybe they're wrong about why. You know, the immediate post-war period was this hint that country had demonstrated that collective action worked, rationing worked, national mobilization worked. We could have directed that energy into a collective flourishing, into public health, into genuine community, into a psychological infrastructure that took suffering seriously,
因为我认为阴谋论的本能，再次强调，总是正确的，或者说不总是，但当人们告诉你他们受到了伤害时，请相信他们。也许他们对原因的判断是错的。你知道，战后初期曾有迹象表明，这个国家已经证明了集体行动是有效的，配给制是有效的，国家动员是有效的。我们本可以将那种能量引导到集体繁荣、公共卫生、真正的社区以及一种认真对待痛苦的心理基础设施中，
and we chose a suburb. And the 60s were this hinge, you know, the civil rights movement, the women's movement, the environmental movement, the human potential movement, all independently arrived at this similar insight, which was individual suffering reflects structural conditions, and structural conditions can change. And psychology could have absorbed that,
但我们选择了郊区生活。60年代是一个转折点，你知道，民权运动、妇女运动、环保运动、人类潜能运动，所有这些运动都独立地得出了一个相似的见解，即个人的痛苦反映了结构性条件，而结构性条件是可以改变的。心理学本可以吸收这一点，
and instead it sided with the efficiency revolution, and it pathologized those movements. or it was embarrassed by them because they didn't speak the language of a hard science. And in the early 90s, there was this hinge point. You know, Clinton tried and failed at health care reform. In the moment where mental health parity could have become law, you know, the moment where the managed care revolution could have been regulated instead of legitimized, there always will be a bureaucracy.
但它却站在了效率革命一边，并将这些运动病理化了。或者说，它因为这些运动没有使用硬科学的语言而感到尴尬。在90年代初，出现了一个转折点。你知道，克林顿在医疗改革上尝试并失败了。在心理健康平等本可以成为法律的时刻，在管理式医疗革命本可以被监管而不是被合法化的时刻，官僚机构总是会存在的。
We can't get rid of them. I'm not advocating for going back to, you know, Bronze Age mythology. But a lot of influencers do, and I think this is why. I think that's why they're telling people that's more meaningful. I would say I'm a little bit more of a realist. I don't think that's possible. You know, the industry organized effectively in the 90s, but the reformers didn't. And then the window closed.
我们无法摆脱它们。我并不是主张回到青铜时代的神话中去。但很多网红确实这么做了，我想这就是原因。我想这就是为什么他们告诉人们那样更有意义。我会说我更现实一点。我不认为那是可能的。你知道，行业在90年代有效地组织起来了，但改革者没有。然后机会之窗就关闭了。
And then after 2008, there's this other hinge. You had a financial crisis that made visible that systems were producing outcomes that no one voted for. Occupy happened. Whoever you voted for, you did not get, and increasingly don't get what you vote for. And Occupy happened, and the Tea Party happened. both for these responses to the same wound. And one got absorbed by the right-wing populism. Well, both of them got absorbed by right-wing populism.
而在2008年之后，出现了另一个转折点。金融危机让人们清楚地看到，系统产生的结果并非任何人所投票支持的。占领华尔街运动发生了。无论你投给谁，你都没有得到，而且越来越得不到你投票支持的东西。占领运动发生了，茶党运动也发生了。两者都是对同一创伤的反应。其中一个被右翼民粹主义吸收了。好吧，两者都被右翼民粹主义吸收了。
And one got absorbed by this kind of myth of democratic incrementalism of we're going to do something later, so just kind of believe in us and then later we might do something. Neither produced structural reform. The opportunity passed. I'm not siding with any of those guys. I'm just saying that's kind of where the energy went. And then at the hinge point, you know, at each one,
其中一个被那种民主渐进主义的神话所吸收，即我们以后会做点什么，所以只要相信我们就行，以后我们可能会做点什么。两者都没有产生结构性改革。机会错失了。我并不站在他们任何一方。我只是说能量就是那样流向了那里。然后在每一个转折点，你知道，在每一个点上，
There was this road that was not taken. And at each hinge point, there was an identifiable people that made, you know, identifiable decisions. But the paranoid theorist who says things are being done to us is, you know, they're correct about that. Things were done. Things continue to be done. But the part of the theorists, the part they get wrong is imagining that there's villains
都有一条未被选择的道路。在每一个转折点，都有可识别的人做出了可识别的决定。但是，那些认为事情是被人为操纵的偏执理论家，你知道，他们在这一点上是正确的。事情确实被做了。事情还在继续被做。但理论家们搞错的部分是想象存在着恶棍
in a circle that are doing this thing. There's not a room. There's no cabal. Now, what there is is a network of incentive structures, each operating according to its own logic, mandatory localized logic, and each producing outcomes that harm millions of people and benefit very few people, and no single actor is responsible for that aggregate, which is in some ways worse, because what do you do?
在一个圈子里做这些事。并没有这样一个房间。没有阴谋集团。现在，存在的是一个激励结构网络，每一个都按照自己的逻辑、强制性的局部逻辑运作，每一个都产生损害数百万人利益却只让极少数人受益的结果，而没有任何单一的参与者对这种总量负责，这在某种程度上更糟糕，因为你该怎么办？
Because if there was a cabal, you could overthrow it. But the incentive structure is harder to overthrow. It exists in everyone's daily choices, and it lives in the software, and it lives in these billing codes, and it makes everyone, somehow complicit, even the people who can diagnose the system accurately. And the incentive structure means that there's fewer and fewer of those people. And here's the takeaway. The conspiracy theorists is not really your enemy.
因为如果有一个阴谋集团，你可以推翻它。但激励结构更难推翻。它存在于每个人的日常选择中，存在于软件中，存在于这些计费代码中，它使每个人在某种程度上都成为共犯，即使是那些能准确诊断系统的人也是如此。而激励结构意味着这样的人越来越少。这就是结论。阴谋论者并不是你真正的敌人。
They're the canary in the coal mine, right? You know, they're hurting in a specific way, and they have correctly perceived something that is wrong, and they've misidentified what. And the reason that they've misidentified what is wrong, is that the culture no longer provides any kind of accurate vocabulary for what is wrong. And the institutions that should have now abdicated that responsibility, I would argue. And if you dismiss the people who participate in these movements as stupid, that they need to read more Wikipedia or they need to watch the news that you watch,
他们是煤矿里的金丝雀，对吧？你知道，他们以一种特定的方式感到痛苦，他们正确地察觉到了某种错误，但他们误判了原因。他们误判了错误原因的原因是，文化不再为错误提供任何准确的词汇。而本应承担这一责任的机构，我认为，已经放弃了责任。如果你把参与这些运动的人斥为愚蠢，认为他们需要多读维基百科或者需要看你所看的新闻，
you're confirming their suspicion that the mainstream has nothing to offer them. If you engage them on a level of fact-checking, their specific claims, you miss what the claims are actually expressing. The claims are expressing a wound. The wound is real. And the wound is usually not what the claim says it is, but addressing the wound is the only intervention that has a chance here of working.
你就在证实他们的怀疑，即主流媒体对他们毫无价值。如果你在事实核查的层面上与他们接触，针对他们具体的说法，你就错过了这些说法实际上所表达的内容。这些说法表达了一种创伤。创伤是真实的。而创伤通常不是说法本身所指的那样，但解决创伤是这里唯一可能有效的干预措施。
And this is what therapy has done best. It listens to the symptoms, as communication, it doesn't argue with the hallucination. And asks what the hallucination is trying to say. And the patient who believes the CIA is implanting thoughts is not arguing for a correct theory of mind control. They're telling you that something foreign has entered them and that they cannot expel it and that they do not feel safe in their own head
这就是心理治疗做得最好的地方。它将症状视为一种交流，它不与幻觉争论，而是询问幻觉试图表达什么。那个认为中情局在植入思想的病人，并不是在争论一种正确的精神控制理论。他们是在告诉你，某种外来的东西进入了他们，他们无法将其驱逐，并且他们在自己的头脑中感到不安全，
and that nobody has ever taken them seriously and that they don't feel safe and that's where you start that's where psychology starts you don't have to explain these systems you don't even have to listen to this podcast to be a better therapist just start there at the base of the brain not at the top the fact that they don't feel safe is what's important And the conspiracy theory at this cultural scale is the same phenomenon. It's the closest the collective can come to articulating the wound, given the vocabulary that's available in each decade as the wound changes. And it always will evolve faster than our ability to describe it.
而且从来没有人认真对待过他们，他们感到不安全，这就是你开始的地方，这就是心理学开始的地方。你不需要解释这些系统，你甚至不需要听这个播客就能成为一个更好的治疗师，只要从大脑的底部开始，而不是从顶部。他们感到不安全这一事实才是最重要的。而在这种文化规模上的阴谋论也是同样的现象。这是集体在描述创伤时所能达到的最接近的方式，考虑到每十年随着创伤的变化而可用的词汇。它总是会比我们描述它的能力进化得更快。
But that's the job of psychology. You know, is to build a better vocabulary, a faster one, because these things are moving at light speed, to offer culture a more accurate language for what has accurate. actually been done to it. That's what I like about what Jung is, and that's why I also think that a lot of Jungian classical Jungian analysis is out of date. And the answer to fixing psychology is not just to hold on to that and make everyone a Jungian analyst. It's to learn from the process of what these people, these early pioneers were doing. They were talking about their culture.
但这就是心理学的工作。你知道，就是要建立一个更好的词汇表，一个更快的词汇表，因为这些事情正以光速移动，为文化提供一种更准确的语言来描述它实际上经历了什么。这就是我喜欢荣格的地方，这也是为什么我也认为许多荣格的经典分析已经过时了。修复心理学的答案不仅仅是坚持这一点，让每个人都成为荣格分析师。而是要从这些早期先驱所做的事情的过程中学习。他们是在谈论他们的文化。
They weren't necessarily talking about ours. We can still learn a lot from them. But I don't know that talking about anima-ananimous and archetypes is really going to fix everybody today. You know, American Psych has done this. You know, they, in this episode, we're looking at why they did it. They did it not because of things that they built in most of these cases, but by territory that they ceded to other industries. And I want to hold this energy like a ghost. I want to name what this episode, you know, has kind of been revolving around
他们不一定是在谈论我们的。我们仍然可以从他们那里学到很多。但我不知道谈论阿尼玛、阿尼姆斯和原型是否真的能解决今天所有人的问题。你知道，美国心理学界已经这样做了。你知道，在这一集中，我们正在审视他们为什么这样做。他们这样做不是因为他们在大多数情况下构建了什么，而是因为他们割让给其他行业的领地。我想像幽灵一样保持这种能量。我想点出这一集，你知道，一直围绕着的主题，
because the last one and this one are the two kind of messy, soft, wide open looser theses before we just get back to the fast-paced history of the first two episodes. Every era, psychology inherits a problem that it doesn't create.
因为上一集和这一集是两个比较混乱、柔软、宽泛、松散的论点，在我们回到前两集快节奏的历史之前。在每个时代，心理学都继承了一个它自己没有创造的问题。
In every era, psychology had tools that might have helped. In every era, psychology chose to use those tools in service of individual adjustment rather than collective understanding. And in every era, because it was afraid of the culture, afraid of the politics, afraid of its own survival,
在每个时代，心理学都有可能提供帮助的工具。在每个时代，心理学都选择将这些工具用于个人适应，而不是集体理解。而在每个时代，因为它害怕文化，害怕政治，害怕自身的生存，
it gave up. And so we now live inside of this accumulated, compounded interest of all of this unprocessed wound from the last 30 to 70 years. And our bodies feel it and our sleep fills it and our children feel it and the anxiety epidemic is not a mystery. And the loneliness epidemic is not a mystery. And the opioid epidemic is not a mystery. And they're not even really new.
它放弃了。所以我们现在生活在过去30到70年所有这些未处理创伤的累积复利之中。我们的身体感受到了，我们的睡眠感受到了，我们的孩子感受到了，焦虑流行病不是一个谜。孤独流行病不是一个谜。阿片类药物流行病不是一个谜。它们甚至不是什么新鲜事。
It's just that the old cycle is now happening like 15 times as fast. And the meaning crisis epidemic is not really a mystery either. They are unprocessed collective trauma. And they look like things that you can medicate. But they're not because they're a collective situation. And the wound speaks. Like it always has. And the question has never been.
只是旧的循环现在发生的速度快了15倍。意义危机流行病也不是一个谜。它们是未处理的集体创伤。它们看起来像是你可以用药物治疗的东西。但它们不是，因为它们是一种集体状况。创伤在说话。就像它一直以来那样。而问题从来不是，
whether the wound is speaking. The question is whether do we have the apparatus to listen to what it is saying anymore. If we can build something that serves a different purpose, something that might actually be the wall the wound is speaking to.
创伤是否在说话。问题是我们是否还有能力去倾听它在说什么。如果我们能建立一些服务于不同目的的东西，一些可能真正成为创伤所面对的墙的东西。
But in part six, we'll get back to the history of the pace of the first two and three episodes. We're going to look at that wall. History looping through your throat. Cold machines, the wounds your soul.
但在第六部分，我们将回到前两三集那种节奏的历史。我们将审视那堵墙。历史在你的喉咙里循环。冰冷的机器，你灵魂的创伤。
Bear it through the tangled words. Cold machines, warm. You're singing something in me shakes. I'm holding on to every mistake. Hey, guys. Thank you for listening to the series. I want to point out you can get this in almost every podcast library out there,
在纠结的言语中忍受。冰冷的机器，温暖。你唱的东西在我体内震动。我紧紧抓住每一个错误。嘿，伙计们。感谢收听这个系列。我想指出，你几乎可以在所有的播客库中找到它，
including YouTube, Apple Music, all of them. Please subscribe if you enjoy it or go back and listen to the beginning if you're starting. And check out the website, get therapy,pringham.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
包括YouTube、Apple Music，所有这些平台。如果你喜欢，请订阅，或者如果你刚开始听，请回去听开头。并查看网站，get therapy, pringham.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。